I don't think about going to make such a drug,
so it's the price in my heart
[Music]
I'm Junichi Daima.
There are about 3 reports, etc. for
35 years.  As you can see, it was like this when I made it over
[Music]
me
. I
think it's about Ijon Track a Flavor Decoration Track
.
I think it's attractive because you can run with your own way of life, your hometown, your family, etc.
Making a truck is our enthusiasm, and the
name is Yoshikazu Yamada.
This car is called Ryuyumaru, and it's
about a few da prefecture books.
The
name is Kikuchi Masakai,
and I think that the causal curve is rising, which is close to 10 million in total.
It's said that it's scary, but
if you look at the sky, you'll see such a cute color and a cute
trap
.
But if you think that you're happy, I'd
be grateful for that.
I definitely want you to leave it in the culture.
[Music]